[Music]
now the present American grand strategy
basically says nuclear weapons can only
be possessed by countries that we like
and they cannot be possessed by
countries that we don't like so if
countries we don't like try and get
nuclear weapons we will move heaven and
earth to stop them that's the basic
story as a console to that we basically
would prefer that no other countries get
nuclear weapons either because it just
complicates our lives right now in a
perfect world it would be nice if there
were no other nuclear weapon States
except the United States right but there
are already several other nuclear weapon
states other than the United States
we've learned how to live with other
nuclear weapon states right and if you
look at the kinds of policies that it
takes to keep other powers from doing in
their national security interests inside
their own borders with their own money
what it is they conceive as being
necessary for their national security to
try and dictate to them what they can
and cannot do is a big job and you need
a hegemonic position to be able to do
that you need decisive crushing military
superiority and you may even need to be
able to invade them right and if you
look at the arguments about Iran and
about North Korea as they've unfolded
over the last 10 years and as are being
discussed today right the question
lurking in the background all the time
is if you can't get them to negotiate
away these capabilities which they seem
to want for their own reasons you should
be willing to fight a preventive war not
a pre-emptive war not attacking them
before they attack you when you think
they're getting ready to attack you but
attacking them now because you think
there might be a problem later and you'd
rather not deal with it so you're gonna
have war now to avoid some kind of war
later right and it seems pretty good if
the war is cheap but the wars are not
cheap right because rubbing out in other
countries nuclear weapons is turns out
to be a big
you've got to destroy factories
laboratories
you've got to wreck their economy you've
got to keep the economy squeezed you
have to kill people or get or kidnapped
them scientists engineers right if you
want to prevent a moderately
technologically advanced country and
here we're talking North Korea which is
really nothing special from getting this
old technology of nuclear weapons it's
now an old technology it's not a mystery
right you really need to be able to to
to get your your hands around their neck
and squeeze it and keep squeezing right
so the question is how many times with
how many places are you willing to do
this how men often are you willing to
wage preventive Wars how many countries
do you want to be in a constant this
kind of relationship with right these
are the questions you have to ask now if
we have it I'd like to have an honest
debate about this the United States
right I don't even think we have an
honest debate because the way this the
way the debate has happened is it will
be very bad if they got nuclear weapons
we have to do something about it all
options are on the table
what kind of euphemism is all options
are on the table war is on the table
well what kind of war is on the table
how many wars are on the table what are
the likelihood of success what are the
unintended consequences of wars to
prevent nuclear proliferation alright
these are questions we should debate we
should ask we should answer right now my
problem with nuclear weapons is rather
different I believe that America knows
how to deter countries that have nuclear
weapons countries that have nuclear
weapons are not gonna attack the United
States because if they do we're going to
annihilate them we'll be very sad for us
it will be even sadder for them right
they're mostly small nuclear powers we
were a great at large nuclear power
right the whole thing would be very very
very sad and tragic and it's easy for
the other side to know how tragic it's
going to be because our nuclear forces
are not a secret right we have fifteen
hundred warheads on a variety of
delivery systems and we can rekt pretty
much any country in the world right
that's the residual of our Cold War for
and we are getting ready to spend a
trillion dollars modernizing that for us
to keep it tip-top shape
I think deterrence we can do so what do
I worry about I worry about not nuclear
weapons in the hands of States but
nuclear weapons that are not in the
hands of States I worry about nuclear
weapons that are lost nuclear weapons
that are stolen nuclear weapons that are
poor aligned right nuclear weapons are
sold off the back of trucks right so
what do you do about that well people
who believe in the non-proliferation
story will say well this is just another
reason to prevent more stage from
getting nuclear weapons I say yes but
what about all the states that already
have nuclear weapons including some that
I'm guessing don't really have very
great can really terrific controls so my
view is our nuclear proliferation policy
is directed at the wrong thing in the
wrong problem what we want to do is make
sure that nuclear weapons are in the
hands of states remain in the hands of
States any state that has nuclear
weapons we should be talking to them
about best practices to ensure that
nobody sells nobody steals nobody loses
nobody breaks right this is this
requires a lot of application a lot of
organization right to be a responsible
nuclear power is hard work it took us a
long time to learn how to do it right
we've actually in the past taught others
how to do it this should be the the
thing that we focus on in the world from
the nuclear weapons problem right
because once nuclear weapons are not in
the hands of States in the hands of
individuals or groups then deterrence
becomes hard because Rev a radical group
a terrorist group a millennial group and
I don't mean the generation I mean
people who imagine some you know magic
moment where history is gonna be
transformed right they they you can't
deter you've got they've got nothing
that they value that you can threaten to
retaliate against countries have many
things they value that you could threat
it's all our aid against these groups
may have nothing did you can retaliate
again so it's very important to keep
nuclear weapons out of their hands
[Music]